with calls for a no-fly zone over
ukraine intensifying the white house
announced u.s president joe biden will
head to brussels next week to attend a
special nato meeting over russia's
invasion of ukraine his goal is to meet
in person face to face with his european
counterparts and talk about and assess
where we are at this point in the
conflict the white house would not say
whether that trip will include any
visits to the ukrainian border or
meeting with ukrainian president
vladimir zelinsky who has been pushing
for a no-fly zone over his country
nato allies including the u.s oppose the
no-fly zone as it would put nato and
russian planes in direct conflict and
potentially lead to nuclear war still
secretary of defense lloyd austin is
meeting with nato defense ministers for
a two-day gathering at the alliance
headquarters in brussels
[Applause]
earlier in the day zielinski addressed
the canadian parliament and made his
case
close the airspace please stop the
bombing how many more cruise missiles
have to fall on our cities
until you
make this happen the u.s continues to
send more help on tuesday the u.s
president signed a spending bill that
included
13.6 billion dollars for ukrainian
security and humanitarian assistance
we're moving urgently to further
augment the support to the brave people
of ukraine
as they defend their country
we're also going to be better positioned
to provide for the rapidly growing
humanitarian needs of the ukrainian
people the money provides aid for
ukrainian refugees in ukraine and in
neighboring nations it also gives
ukraine military equipment and training
the ukrainian president will make his
case for a no-fly zone when on wednesday
he addresses a joint session of the u.s
congress
kimberly hellcat al jazeera the white
house